guys good news and bad news bad news is
you cannot see me on the road any longer
doing my material because I finished my
special and it will be coming out in the
spring of 24 thank you Chicago you are
amazing here's the good news when I'm
not doing my solo tour I'm doing the
group tour so come see me and the guys
from practical jokers T our kicks off in
just a couple of weeks in January we're
in Highland California we're in Vegas
baby at Resorts World Theater and then
at the mullet arena in Tempe Arizona
then we got the impractical Joker's Cruz
with Eric Andre and a ton of other
people Felipe Esparza steveo Adam Ray um
just a ton of great stuff happened on
that one and there still are some cabins
left it's our fifth one it's going to be
insane get shipfaced tocom or shipfaced
cruise.com come along that's January
22nd to the 26th from there we go to
Florida we're doing the Hard Rock in
Hollywood we're doing the uh seminal
Casino in Tampa and uh then the Hard
Rock Casino in Cincinnati uh then in
April Youngstown Ohio at the golli
center a couple at the Chicago theater
right there a couple at Foxwoods uh and
then in June Atlanta at the Symphony
Hall mobile Mobile Alabama at the Sanger
theater so we are going to be all over
uh check out impracticaljokers.com or
really just go to SAC comedy.com to get
tickets I hope to see you guys on the
road this is the last second leg and
last leg of the Joker tour as well so
when we're done with this one Show's
retired you can't see it anymore so hope
to see you guys on the road and look out
for my special Next Year Chrissy
California that's who I am I got a show
January 12th in El Cahone AK Elon
California San Diego area Magnolia
Theater and then January 13th at the
wilter in Los Angeles these are Big
Shows this is the only time I'm going to
be in California Chris DC comedy.com for
Ticky wikies then February 2nd at the
Ryman Auditorium in Nashville which one
of I one of the most beautiful venues in
the country and then February 3rd
Washington DC and then I end everything
February 8th uh in Reno Nevada Christy
comedy.com for
Ticky uh don't be a fake don't be a
flake don't run away from your feelings
babe don't be afraid don't be ashamed
don't hesitate to say hey bab hey bab
hey bab hey bab hey bab hey bab Here
Comes hey bab it's time for hey bab so
much hey bab to Cate hey
bab OJ
Simpson not a Jew hey babe how are you
babe first of all let me tell you
something you're looking felt you're
looking skinny you know that now you've
reached the new phase you've reached the
skinniest s I've ever met FaZe no no
that's not true this is the skinniest
what you like but whatever whatever you
want to take with you I've never met a
skinniest s in my life no when I met you
I was this this this this I don't
believe it really I don't I would say
refuse to believe I refuse to believe
and where does that get you well let me
tell you something I refuse to believe I
have come along and I do believe in
Christ tell me some things you refuse to
believe start with this and we'll move
forward some things I refuse to believe
yeah so you refuse to believe that I was
ever this weight since you've known me
yes I refuse to believe you're ever that
weight since I've known you I um I
refused I refuse to believe that there
are beings in other Realms that are
feeding off our guilt anxiety and
negative emotions giving themselves
power and trapping us in a NeverEnding
Prison Planet Loop okay like an energy
vampire I refuse to believe that even
though that has been being pushed out
more and more I refuse to believe that
um I I I refuse to believe I refuse to
believe that's to the one we all know
you're going to say what I refuse to
believe happy Hol holidays oh in Santa
no cuz all Hal Hala I refuse to believe
in the Holocaust but probably thought
you were going to but but I do believe
in the Holocaust um I I do absolutely
believe I was there um my grand my
family members might have been do you
believe uh in the 1986 Mets I do believe
in the 1986 Mets you believe in the US
hockey team from 1980 I do I Believe In
The 1975 oh okay do you believe in okay
I believe um I believe in Christ or Our
Savior Jesus Christ I have come along
about a book I've been reading called
the case for Christ which I could talk
about at length
where do you find the time to read I
have a I envy it I I love it I have I
admire it I should say I have a a system
uh that's somewhat in place day to day
system you believe in the system I
believe in where I wake up every day at
5:30 if I can and I go down what here's
what I do I go down I wake up I sit I
let my feet hit the floor for 5 seconds
and I just sit and I kind of try to just
take a second you ground yourself I
ground myself I try to slowly wake up I
do about some some head rolls I get up I
brush my teeth for approximately 1
minute or I sing the Happy Birthday song
three to four times in my head the
American version um then I go downstairs
I and that what does that do for you
does that make you feel like the Happy
Birthday song well it's just dentists
say that you should sing the Happy
Birthday song a few times to the kids
you guys hear that yeah you heard of
that vena's heard of it Vena is dressed
with a jean Jack Vena looks like she's
on the cast of Yellowstone right now
ven is dressed like Kevin
cner you either you look like that or
like like a Wu Tang member from 1992
like a big car heart ven is wearing a
dope car heart jean jacket I think I
actually have the same one you heard
that the kids are supposed to uh sing
happy birthday so they could remember to
brush their teeth yeah you're you're
supposed to do that for washing your
hands and brushing your teeth yes wash
your hands or brushing your teeth I
never heard that so that's a big one so
I do that and then what I do is I come
down here's the same exact routine when
I hit the routine right this is what I
do I come downstairs what I did today
come downstairs I fill a tall glass of
water I let it sit there for a few
minutes to get to chill off tepin I wait
about 5 minutes during that time of the
5 minutes what I either do is start to
prepare the kids lunch if if Jasmine
hasn't already done it the night before
or I sit down and I put on Sports Center
and I just catch up on whatever the
latest Sporting News not war news Just
Sports something easy to take in sure
then I take my 50 migs of lardin and I
take my claran D lardin lardin blood
pressure medicine I didn't know you were
on that 100% since when about you
haven't on that since I know you 18
months nope I refuse to believe it you
refuse to I'll prove it is it working at
times yes at times no it depends on the
stress situation well then I think maybe
that's a No it should work all the time
no well here's the thing here's what
counterbalances that is it would it
would work but for example today W work
would work um we work what it it would
work but today I took my lard and took
my clar and had my coffee I read uh one
page from the daily dad which I read
every day one page from the daily stoic
that I read every day and then I try to
read one page is very manageable yes and
that's how you is that how you do it
well that's how I start warming up just
years to get through a book though yes
yes that's how it literally well daily
dad takes exactly one calendar year
there 365 Pages oh it's meant to be yes
so but but what I do is I that as a
warm-up cuz I read two pages and then I
get the ball rolling and then I read 10
to 15 pages of whatever book I'm reading
at this time it's case for Christ how
long does it take
you why and why is it case for Christ
because I I wanted you have time for
case for Christ I've been reading case
for Christ I just I just finished making
a case for him is that what it is like
the Au Le trouble is is making he went
in as a non-believer and he came out as
a Believer it strawberry strud le le le
Lew Str okay yep he he went in as a
non-believer he's an investigative
journalist for the Chicago uh Tribune I
think was uh was and and and then he
goes in and he starts to he um
interviews all these Skeptics the
everyone from Skeptics theologians to
theologians to the to Theologian vs to
Bill Mars to Bill Mars to everyone and
then he comes to the conclusion at the
end of the book which I am not there yet
he'll be there in a couple years be
there in a couple years he comes to
Second Coming that he is a he does
actually believe so already in the first
six chapters I'm starting to slowly
believe more day by day and people
comment I talked about this on stavros's
podcast last week and then people in the
comments have been hitting me with you
know I'm supporting uh pedophilia and
all that stuff and and oh because of the
Catholic church and well we can't we
can't judge the entire Catholic Church
on a 2,000 bed and they come at me and I
and I say and what I I say to them let
him be let him be upon you say that to
the St Peter when you reach the gates do
not say it yet to me say it to say it to
him nice that's what I say so I I do you
think that when you Clos the book cuz
you you don't believe now is that is
that what's right you're on the fence
it's fair was on the fence I'm on the
I'm here either either Jesus Christ
himself created this whole world or it
is an entity from another realm well I
went to Catholic School from
kindergarten a senior year of college
yes I don't believe but you have to say
so did I no I I just you have to be a
skeptic in this world it's the only way
you'll survive you have to be I'm open
to it open to it but what do I know so
for me I go hard you know facts I I deal
in black and white cookies and and they
so far the the the theologians who who
he has interviewed you know Yale level
educated people are all saying that
there's enough corroborating evidence to
at least say that he was real he did
exist and the people at the time did say
these miracles happen the way the way uh
Matthew mark Luke and John said it
happened but I'm not I'm only six
chapters in and as you said doing the
math I still have another 300 pages to
go so if I'm reading 10 if I'm reading
15 pages a day Delilah if I'm reading 15
pages a day and I have 300 pages left
how many days first of all are we
multiplying adding subtracting or
dividing and then how many days will it
take me to get through the 20 days 20
more days and show show your
work well what I did was I took 15 pages
a day and I multiplied that by 10 which
is one of the easier Tim taes to know
and I know that you just added zero to
that now did you use Daddy's
multiplication cheat sheat or do you
have it up here please don't insult
me this is a fairly easy one I got to
150 you double that it's 300 so 10 days
plus 10 days is 20 days right boom bap
that's how I did that yeah um by the way
I just [__] myself yeah my daughter she
got she lost she was she would almost
got 100 on test but they gave her 999
because they took one point off because
on all her test she's been instead of
putting Delila she's writing Delila
d.com and she lost she lost a point and
now now it's got to the point where the
teachers I said I can't believe you
should be add she's branding herself you
should be adding her book bag says
Delila d.com yeah she got it that's what
she wanted does he doesn't is out of
touch with today's day and age yes yeah
so but but anyway with that being said
so that's where I find the time to read
is I wake up very early I try I have to
before because then the first kid wakes
up about 6:15 6:30 so then by then once
you hear the first call for you know
usually mom I have to then you're but
you've already been up you you're like
on a boxer schedule I try to wake up
yeah and do that and then right but I
try but but not cuz sometimes sometimes
it'll the alarm will go off at 6:45 and
or or I'll get woken up by one of the
kids and then I can't read [__] it you
just don't get up and you don't you
don't you you don't uh even respond to
anyone who talks to you in the morning
you just you just close them all out
yday that yesterday I had that plan
yesterday I had that I had the plan to
wake up and do what I did today but I
was exhausted I woke up I said not today
Christ and I went back to sleep yeah
okay let me tell you I I mentioned this
before but I was in in religion class in
high school I had got like a 100 on
every test and then I did the extra
credit assignment on top of that because
there were teachers that would give you
like 102 average there were in some and
that would help balance out the the BS
and I got a 100 average and then I did a
four points of extra credit a 99 average
Four Points of extra I supposed to get
103 right she gave me a 99 which is what
Jasmine's fever is right now exactly 103
God please God love 103 she's up there
baby oh that's that's big I was going
she was like I you here she she I she's
like she told me to feel my feel her
head this morning I felt it and she goes
is it warm I said it's all the way
up in her face she's like all I do is
win slowly
dying the heat is on how' you know that
um no yeah so she said I went up to her
in class and I said uh I I should have
103 and she said why' you give me 99 she
just looked me and she said cuz only
Jesus is perfect right remember that
there's a lot of schools that do that
and then I said I said that's totally
not fair though like you didn't tell me
that I did the extra credit like you
should have told me I was capped like I
did all this work and I put up a nice
argument in front of the class and then
she got a little mad I remember I told
you this and then she turned to me she
was like this far away from my face cuz
I was at her desk and I wasn't letting
up letting up on it and she turned to me
and she just went you are acting like a
genuine
ass
I was like man for a guy that came in
here and blew the doors off this place
with 103 average this is the way you
treat people speaking of speaking of are
genuine asses and and somebody who needs
Christ I'd like to play this is for real
this is not AI generated I'd like to
play a little exerpt from Eric Adams
inter exerpt exerpt excerpt um I'd like
to play a little a little um from um
mayor of New York Eric Adams appearance
on Pix 11 News two nights ago this is
100% real this is corroborated not by
Lee strob but the author of case for
Christ but it is corroborated by others
and it is real you guys know what he's
about to play I thought it was genuinely
AI generated you heard this in the news
already touch yeah here we
go only let the light of Christ touch
you here we go here we go Mr Mayor we've
come to the end of what was a very
eventful 202 23 right so when you look
at the totality of the year if you had
to describe it and it's tough to do in
one word what would that word be and
tell me why uh New York uh this is a
place where every day you wake up you
could experience everything from a plane
crashing into our Trade Center to a a
person who's celebrating a new business
that's open uh this is a very very
complicated City and that's why it's the
greatest City on the globe there it is
oh my my God first of all one word he's
like New York New York so funny but but
that's what he went with that's what the
role deck so he went for the lowest of
the low in history at the and I cut it
off before but the last thing that's
morning that's morning wpx in the
morning WX and more and then he ended
all he went this was been hey
babe he's like he's like well you can
experience everything from the Trade
Center to crash to the building which
was around 907 right at this time yeah I
mean could you imagine I mean listen it
is very difficult to be a politician
but it bird just hit the window no no no
no it feels like it oh wow you heard
that though I heard that it feels like a
bird hit the window we're coming to you
live from uh a new a new yet another hey
babe studio um by the way this is we we
we realize it's different yes oh yeah
it's different we're in transition we
are in transition like d like d Roa yes
D roza loves out of the old space d Roa
loves people in transition so mayor Eric
Adams his uh his his his approval rating
I I I have seen perfectly that it's
pretty low then I would say it's low has
he what has he done and just just fool
around I would say I he coming and done
watch just made some silly comments and
stuff yeah what what has he done that's
actionable does anyone know it's what
has he done that's actionable he shuts
down the libraries now once a week
budget cuts really um yeah he really
does yeah he's talking about you know
the police force how much should we save
from the cumulative Librarians pay for
one day a week how much does the city
say I'm Pro Adams cuz he was interviewed
by the great Christ Stefano he was on
Zoom Co get out of here I swear to God
wa he was already the mayor no he was
running to be mayor he he came on the
show he came on the podcast live from
his living room that he was living in
right he was he was zooming in from City
Hall and he couldn't answer certain
questions because like he was in like a
government space he was sleeping in City
Hall remember at that time wasn't he no
he said that he might sleep there
sometimes he was joking but he was like
talking about what a health advocate he
is and how much he loves New York a
vegan did he bring up the Trade
Center he was he's like I know CO's
happening but there's another tragedy
I'd like to BR I said I said to Mayor
Adams what you know future mayor Adams
what is it that you love about New York
the most he said well of course
9911 was it a segment of the episode he
was on the he was our guest on the
episode oh my God how'd you get through
that we it act we were on Zoom I was you
didn't know a lot about him did you
research I was doing it no um how did he
come I think you knew him spitball with
potential May for minutes over Zoom
during I kept saying you know you should
not be doing the show because this is
what anyone who's running against you
just has to point to you being a guest
on my podcast as if to say you're out
right you should not you you told him
that yeah and he didn't care oh he
became
mayor oh James Al no was it James aler
yes James aler the great James aler who
used to own St up New York the the
Bitcoin genius um Johnny Bitcoin he he
well I don't know where the hell James
aler is I have not smoken him nobody
knows where he is he does not return
text James if you're alive please send
me a smoke signal he is the one who
connect he digitized himself now all of
his value is all of his value he's
turned into actual crypto he um babes I
got a new favorite soap and I ain't
lying I'm a soap guy I'm a candle guy
and I'm a soap guy if I'm nothing else
uh Dr Squatch I have tried the entire
line now the scents are unbelievable see
here's what I didn't like about my old
soaps first of all I go and you buy
these handcrafted soaps sometimes and
they like cut and they're like on a
table they're not even packaged and you
feel like you're buying produce or
something and then you get it home and
it smells good at first but then the
smell wears out this is such good
combinations and such good smells fresh
Falls Birchwood Breeze wood barrel
Bourbon there are so many different um
and it's there's so many different uh
scents but it also high performance
natural product 98% of this is natural
okay B Corp certified no harmful
ingredients I'll tell you what I do I I
like to do sometimes I like to wash up
top with one scent the mid with another
and then the bottom with a different bar
and then I'm walking out of there like
with three different cents on me and I
nobody can stop me at that point um buy
three soaps and get three soaps for free
that's a $28 in savings uh it's like
getting each bar for four bucks the
holidays are here why not do it free
shipping okay this offer is only valid
for new customers here we go what pay
attention what you put on your body men
don't normally do that so let's do it
right now Dr Squatch is offering our
listeners a huge savings all new
customers will get three free bar of
soaps plus free shipping with any
purchase of three bars just go to
drsquatch.com Bab and receive this buy
three get three offer that's Dr Squatch
dsq ach.com heyab to buy three soaps and
get three free it's time to get all the
daily routine Essentials you'll need to
start feeling good and smelling like a
man
today this episode is sponsored by
better help guys uh I don't know if if
you're all familiar with therapy or not
I've been practicing myself for a long
time I don't practice there I'm not the
therapist but I go to them and uh I
don't think I could really deal without
it because it is it keeps my mind in
tiptop shape I'm not bottling anything
up and uh I would recommend it to anyone
and the reason that I like better help
is because it brings it to you in the
just the easiest most efficient quickest
and simplest way in my opinion
absolutely um it's entirely online it's
designed to be convenient flexible and
uh you know suited to your schedule if
you're thinking of starting it give it a
try with better help just fill out a
brief questionnaire to get match with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge look
holidays are around you're probably
thinking about everybody else but
yourself take a beat the best thing you
can give yourself is self-care right so
why not try betterhelp it's a season of
giving give yourself what you need with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com heyab
today to get 10% off of your first month
that's better help
hp.com
heab he uh he connected us and yeah it
was wild and then he won the mayor
election like the next year but it was
the lowest New York City voting turnout
in New York City history no because Co
nobody but he still won and um when does
he when does he have until I don't know
two years next year no cuz two years two
years would have been pass right maybe
it's three or four years I don't know
what the mayor V but the mayor's in New
York notoriously nobody votes that's
like very notor like we just do not vote
for the mayor yeah
um but H how are you around a piece of
wood like if you had to do woodworking
if I to do woodwork if you had all the
acutron if you had like a table saw and
all types of saws the one's like a like
all those hand saw maybe like a you know
and you had a bunch of different sizes
of wood 2x4s 2x sixes some some plywoods
and I asked you to build me like a uh a
box right I don't know well first first
off let's me a chair could you do it
first off the I'm going to answer your
question but I'd like to know how many
times do you think in if you took all
the craft shops workshops would like
guys workshops wood shops in the world
how many times a day do you think the
word Accutron is said in a actual for
real wood shop probably
probably none none you think I think
maybe I think aan is one of my favorite
words autan is a great word yeah it it
really is a great word because I like
saying the like the cuz I don't feel
like it's one of those words where
people will mock you if you do the
accent no AAL AO yeah yeah yeah yeah
whereas like if you say like she annoys
the crap out of me I'm sure a lot of
people I've heard this but my my lady
when she when she's at like a restaurant
she has to like say a dish she always
hits she turns up the the heat there and
she says like Margarita or something
like that yeah yeah marar yeah and now
she's now it's but not even in her like
she'll say it you know wherever she
thinks like but now now it's it's going
into other words that aren't like Foods
or cultural cuz the other day I heard
her go I was like you have the raincoat
and she's like it's in the thing I'm
like my other rain coat she goes no your
pagonia pagon I was like what did you
just say she goes the Patagonia I was
like it's Patagonia like why are you
saying pagonia I love that we're making
fun of her she has a brain
tumor now there is a postcript to this
it's a slowly growing tumor but I'm in
denial so I just like to say make
believe that like will you stop sound
talking like you're a goddamn
Chilean um so um but I would say if you
if you gave me all the Accra mons and a
piece of wood could I build you a box a
chair let's call it a chair a chair no
how about a uh what's a simple
woodworking thing a Bo in a chair is or
a desk a desk seems hard like a bar What
can you is just a one big piece of wood
the hardest part for all of us would be
the cutting of the wood have you ever
cut wood no have you ever chopped wood
uh no me neither but I am going to start
to embark on doing things like this
because I can't now stand it anymore
that my daughters just don't look at me
as a man at all well when you talk when
you think about all the people in the
history of the world that say that their
daughters don't think about them as a
man and that they want to try to get uh
in Earnest into woodworking how many
people you say they're going to embark
on
it which I don't think enough because
Embark would be the perfect word because
you're saying bark yeah as tree bark ah
yeah you ever cut wood no i' in my life
I've done like maybe my dad or someone
and then there's like the pen mark on it
and you start
going and I swear to Christ if I cut one
piece of wood I cut a million I I I I be
careful on swearing with Christ just
understand who you're talking to
understand you're only on only on
chapter six though I am I'm a chapter
six
Christian I mean by by the time I was
done cutting a 2x4 I was like there's no
way I'll ever do this for ever again in
my life you can't do it no why would I
want to do this do you have a desire now
that the you know people are saying the
world is ending America is ending every
movie you watch is talking about the end
of the world I mean it is it is
literally in your face wherever you go
you'd almost be crazy to think it's not
ending okay do you think now we should
at least try to learn some skills so we
can at least survive an extra week I'll
tell you what happened friend of mine I
used to tell I used to have this running
joke with my friends that like I would I
would be the first one to die if left
alone in the woods or if everything was
reset or if I went back in time I
couldn't tell them how a mirror I
couldn't do anything I don't know how to
start a fire I don't know how a car
works I don't know how a mirror works I
don't know how the camera works I don't
know how the phone works I don't know
how internet works you nothing I don't
know anything right so they bought me a
survival book like this thick the end of
the world survival book and I recently
went into I was in storage getting some
stuff I saw it I took it out I brought
it home right because it's just in your
mind I just at least want to be able to
go through a chapter if I need to that
quick I have and I I've told you this I
think I've spoke about this on this show
I have in my basement four jars of
30-day supplies of fetuccini Alfredo you
just add water to it night vision
goggles iodine tablets a ba a a baby is
this a joke I swear to God I have a gas
mask for adults and one for the baby and
I have but is's a it it will give us 120
days of of sustenance I have questions I
have questions okay iodine tablets n
infection if you get nuked and there's
radiation poris you take iodine tablets
can slow down the radiation so I was
told so they're in tablet form like a p
like you swallow them yeah you just and
and then what you do is if the end have
you ever heard
this yeah yeah so what happens they
saave off radiation they help slow it
down Google it if I I mean that's what
yeah you said that on Amazon and so you
have you have the you have iodine
tablets you literally have gas masks but
this thing has tits yeah yeah yeah go
ahead I know I was like you've been
working out yeah you got some yeah oh I
see it there you go he's blinking not
bad um you you have gas mask for all
ages you have iodine tablets but then
the sustenance you decided to go with
was 150 days worth of fet Alfredo that
what was on sale on Amazon okay so and
then and then what you also do another
fun fact what you should do is if you
feel the end of the world's coming or if
just if you feel like it's you know
there's cuz the thing is if we get nuked
at the end of the world comes it
probably just going to happen so what
you always kind of want to do if you can
and now I done this I have a bathroom
upstairs that nobody uses it's always
filled with water I just fill the
bathtub up and I leave I I know people
you know I went to my mom's house I told
you she had three big bins in her living
room at one time and I was like what's
in there she's like food I'm like food
she's like yeah I opened it up it's
freaking literal like army astronaut
freeze dried food three bins of it yes
of all like it's like beef and all this
stuff and I'm like I pick it up it's
like powder you know whatever I'm like
what are you doing she's like you never
know yeah is this Bas on that new Obama
film well that film is nuts did you see
that film
s okay if you want to be scared if you
truly want to be afraid I live scared
I'm you don't have to if you don't have
like ghost movies demon movies even
serial killer movies I'm like I'll beat
the [__] out of a serial killer they
don't I understand a woman watching it I
get it but it's like I'll throw Ted
Bundy out out of window I mean it's it's
kill or be killed at that point and
you're going to do everything you can
it'll be difficult to especially me you
know think fighting to the death I would
just I think I'll get killed by a serial
killer tonight but but a serial killer
you don't know there a serial killer
until it happens right but just like the
so maybe just carry IOD tablets in your
pocket that's a good point or maybe yeah
just I at least he's kill me I said let
me just eat this fetuccini Alfredo so I
just got to put water in it do you have
a garden hose that instead of strangling
me with it can I feel up fil Alfredo but
but this movie is Scary because it what
is the name of it again with Ethan
and um wait Obama acts in it no I'll
tell you what Happ um the it's um the
new the Leave the World Behind that's
what it's called I heard about this
Ethan Hawk Julia Roberts marcala Ali
it's on yeah yeah yeah I know all about
it yes yes yes someone just watched it
and told me to watch it they said it was
worth watching okay it's worth watching
but you have to go in there is it a
thriller it's a thriller well it's a
thriller but let me tell you something
that and I heard of another one uh I
don't know Iran claw you corroborating
evidence as least trouble does in the
case for Christ so I'm going to give you
corroborating evidence to why it's scary
to me okay okay yeah I was looking if I
had a water but there's water in the
fridge you have a water for some you
want to go to my
bathtub do you really bring a lad so
wait so how does that not uh collect
bacteria it will it's really in case of
Emer bathing well it doesn't collect
bacteria because I also in addition to
the iodine tablets I have a uh uh a
tablet that I could drop in any pool of
water that would disinfect it and make
it clean drinking water did you see
those things did you ever see those
apparatuses they're like a tube and you
could suck up like literal puddle water
and and You by the time it comes out the
other end that I get a Kirk and she gets
a Perry you could put in a toilet you
could put like look you get a Perry I
get air no V was trying to take the
Perry take V is dressed like the mar per
but that Obama movie sparkling if you
want it if not don't I'm not trying to
force per on you that Obama movie is
Scary cuz it kind of feels like he's
like why you ping Obama movie I'll tell
you I'll tell you now so pimp brings up
a good point because I I guarantee you
pimp wrote and directed it and here's
the
controversy yeah if you see a clip from
it it's pimp pimp did it so so what
happened was what happened was is is
Barack says something silly he Zooms in
on he Zooms in on Julia Roberts's eyes
yeah yeah yeah barack's heads upside
down all of a sudden did a roach just
run across the screen so okay so so
basically what the premise of the movie
is I don't want to give too much away
but the premise of the movie is is kind
of the world ending but how it would end
not in a nuclear disaster not in an
alien invasion in a very kind of
predictable preventable way that some
foreign Nation or all of us together
would knock out our cyber grid and then
it go I won't give the movie away but it
goes through the phases of how it
happens realistic and you're kind of
taken back by that we like oh my God and
then at the end of the movie it says
produced by Michelle and Barack Obama
who was the former president obviously
of the United stat yes and there was one
line about being president remember the
guy had it just felt like it was OB it
felt like yes yes and with and with the
former president of the United States
and his wife Barack do you that was a
joke that was for me so obviously Barack
Obama his wife Michelle so so basically
what why it was so kind of made me truly
I couldn't sleep even though there's
nothing I can do about it it is because
we had on the Chrissy chaos podcast a
former CIA agent on and when we asked
him what scares him what keeps him up at
night this was 8 months ago he said it's
not a nuclear Invasion it's not an alien
attack the only thing that a foreign
enemy could get is them knocking out our
power grid and then would set us back to
the Stone Age and a 100 million people
would die in the first month he said so
that and he said our we have the best
arm should he be putting that out there
well he said it's common knowledge that
we have the best army in the world the
best military in the world like no
country can we have he he told us he was
like if somebody if Russia for example
hit us with a nuclear weapon they know
they're getting it right back right they
would get 50 the the entire country be
wiped so so they would only be able to
any country said would only be able to
get one off because we have so many more
he said but that's not the war anymore
that's not the game nobody's going to do
that to us and we're not going to do
that to them cyber stuff he said and
that will [__] all of us he said and
our our cyber security system is is very
weak for our first world country they
run they run like two two two versions
ago of Norton exactly exactly so so
that's what this movie is about and all
the misinformation and kind of you know
the scare like like what would happen
how people would turn on each other
there Civil War and a lot of people feel
well that's we're in people are saying
we're in this what the movie is about
and the movie is about all that
happening yes and it's kind of crazy
because it's like don't give anything
away you know at the end I mean I just
don't know if it's like Julie Roberts
dies no she
doesn't
um no I we name the episode that Julie
Robins
dies and oh yeah dot dot dot no she
doesn't Julie Roberts dies yeah that
might get some clicks um let me ask you
a question directly listeners if I ask
you right now how many subscriptions you
pay for a monthly subscriptions would
you know across all boards no I thought
I did and I definitely didn't because I
signed up for Rocket money which I love
and basically they do all of this for me
I get emails I'm not joking I get emails
um from rocket money and they'll tell me
like you know just really like things
that no one's paying attention to I'm
too busy to so far uh this month You'
spent
$26 more than last month here's your
December spending progress report I am a
man of lists I run by numbers this is
the best thing that ever happened to me
uh my largest purchases this month were
on United Airlines and at a hotel I
won't say which one um they can help you
right here savings opportunity in the
email they sent me we noticed that I
paid about $5.50 extra uh to the
periodical I subscribed to they they're
saying they can negotiate for me to get
it lower just click on the button that
says lower this bill uh I got uh I got
an alert the other day that said
uncategorized transaction detected uh
and and then they list when it was what
it was and so if they can't categorize
it they want to bring your attention to
it it's pretty awesome um so if you had
subscriptions you think you forgot about
any that you paid twice and didn't
realize it this is great for you you can
cancel all the subscriptions from here
it's so easy instead of going to each
one individually it Aggregates all of
them um and it gives you uh alerts like
you said on increase in price rocket
money is personal finance app that finds
and cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps lower
your bills
that's a fact that's what I just said
rocket money has over 5 million users
and has helped save its members an
average of $720 a year with over $500
million in canceled subscriptions damn
stop wasting money on things you don't
use cancel your unwanted subscriptions
by going to Rocket money.com
heyab that's rocket money.com heyab
rocket money.com he babe guys I don't
know if you like sports or comedy or
music or theater and and I don't know if
you leave your house but if you do and
you ever go to one of these live
performances you have to know about game
time okay game time is an app that lets
you buy tickets last minute for the best
price guaranteed um you don't have to
take you take the worrying basically out
of uh take the worrying out of when
you're going to get tickets waiting
online hitting refresh all that stuff
you could just wait until you're ready
that you know you can go as well you
don't have to plan months in advance
okay you get the view directly from the
seat that you bought which I think is
huge okay
um it's every event in your area too so
don't think that it's limited if you if
there's something going on you check
game time okay and they have Flash Deals
they have Zone deals on last minute
tickets and there is this thing called
The Game Time guarantee and that's
that's the big selling point for me it
means you'll always get the best price
if you find tickets in the same section
and a row for Less game time will credit
you 110% of that difference take the
guesswork out of buying tickets with
Game Time download the game time app
create an account and use code hey babe
for $20 off your first purchase terms
apply again create an account redeem
code hey babe h e y b a b e for $20 off
download game time today last minute
tickets lowest price guaranteed okay but
it if I watch it you know me and you
know my tolerance for these things and
you know my general you know where I
start from each day am I going to watch
this then it's did it give you a whole
another bag to carry with your baggage I
mean listen I've been carrying bags you
know for a few years but what I will say
is that it definitely two things two
things have really scared the the car
part scared me the most the car part you
know when they figure out what's going
on with the cars in the highway yes the
car can I tell you that part are you
talking about they tapping into the
self-driving cars and just crashing them
yes no you're not did I guess it right
yes no they're not is that is that
possible there's one scene in the movie
and this the only part of giveaway
there's one scene in the movie where
guess who's not plugging that car in
ever well Teslas Tesla specifically
start coming off the lot and then just
all crashing into the same Tesla allowed
them to do that in the movie I guess
right are they not Teslas in the movie
yeah a lot of
Teslas so yeah so so that that part was
really SC and then the plan's crashing
too do the same thing to the planes so
so but but that can happen now somebody
could they could do that right now yeah
but I don't want to give the guy who
didn't have the idea the idea though no
but that's the thing people can you just
beep beep the last seven minutes what he
what the Cent told us is that they're
the CIA the American government is
preventing this multiple times a day
every day like the whole game is just is
trying to stop this that's what their
life is so they have a whole dedicated
this is going on how do you how are you
a human being and you're assign that
task like you wake up every day you go
downstairs and read a page out of the
daily dad and you feel your feet on the
floor before you brush your teeth this
guy gets up and he's like all right six
times a day the world might blow up let
me just see I'll take it one situation
at a time and I'll save the world one at
a time right how do you how can you even
when I used to watch what's that movie
uh that that show that was on with the
girl Charles in Charge no close the girl
who is like a terrorist specialist oh
home homecoming Homeland Homeland so I
would watch that I watch every season of
that and I would be like how do these
people what's that what' you say
homecoming is all Kanye's album but it's
actually Beyonce oh it's actually
Beyonce how do you I'm like how do these
people have a life how do these people
have a life like how do they it's so
just watching it was depressing like
they they have no well at least they
they don't show that side of it in the
show but like you how do you like how
the how do you that that's your job and
then you go see like the new trolls
movie well that I think the thing that
you have to think about I think I think
two things are happening now in our
societies one I think we're starting to
like evolve to a point where we're
starting to understand that like you
know our life is very finite and there's
so much like danger in the world where
you just are taking a risk every time
you step out of the door even inside
your own house like anything can happen
because we're seeing everything so much
and then I think too that people now I
know what comforts me is turning to
religion in Christ to know that I will
go somewhere uh safe to the kingdom of
heaven if I am gracious enough to be
entered into it CU I do believe right so
um I'd like to read to you from first
second first letter of Paul to the
Corinthians are you trying to get tax
exempt here what are you
doing yeah I mean I am a reverend well
let me ask you are I am which I'm a
reverend yeah I official right and I
could I could host a gathering every
Sunday with a certain amount of people
and document it and apply for a tax
break why don't we do that yeah a lot of
times on Sunday I like to watch football
right I get it but now let me ask you
this what scares you more that that
thing that I just told you about or then
there's another theory coming out I
don't know if pimper ven have heard
about this one tuo Carson talked about a
couple of weeks ago but this has been a
Reddit form that I've read for months my
group chat I have one friend who's like
a survivalist group chat and this is
what he genuinely believes and what
people are starting to genuinely believe
now this stuff shouldn't enter my
[__] this shouldn't enter my
conscious this one is more abstract and
this one sounds crazy but I will send
you the Reddit and you can read it on
your own time during ordinary time which
we're entering uh after this Christmas
holiday in the Christian religion I mean
I take six pills a day for sure okay go
ahead um
so basically what people believe what
there's a good amount of people believe
and now higher-ups in the government and
higher up people are starting to believe
is that what we actually are okay what
we I kind of brief this in the beginning
of the Pod what we actually are is we
are our souls as human beings we're
trapped this is a prison planet and
we're trapped and when you see see this
white light and these other relatives
it's all a trick by another entity that
spaced what they believe with aliens and
it's not up and down it's Realms it's
there's another realm that's happening
right here that we can only see in 3d
but they could see in 4D 560 so they can
but then also all the all the infinity
to the of the so so but what they say is
that so there there's a podcast going on
here right now between two demons two
demons and that they basically we're
calling them demons but they're just in
another realm that basically what they
do is they feed their the energy that
they feed off that they give what gives
them life is our guilt anxiety and
suffering all negative emotions what
gives them life and then when you die
you get trapped in this endless cycle
because when you die you get reborn into
onto this prison planet again whether it
be cuz time if time is happening all at
once then you can go back to the 1500s
and then you just live the other life
and what major celebrities and high
ranking politicians what they think that
they do for this what they think that
Justin Bieber or the obas have done is
made a deal with these entities and said
I will give you my soul to feed off for
eternity you feed off my anxiety
depression and fear but every single
time I die I get reborn into a different
time but I'm always have Fame power and
Fortune always but who's I don't
understand who's thinking how who who
are they asking that of we're saying
major celebrities what they're saying
like that's that's the deal that they
make so like Justin Bieber though with
these entities that live in the other
that they feed off that and there's only
very very high P high frequency you're
losing me now high frequency high
frequency read the case for Christ high
and be found high frequency individuals
like monks are ones that have broken out
of this prison Loop and they are kind of
in the higher frequency the the universe
deals with frequencies so they're
dealing with how and Nikolai Tesla said
that he said if you want to understand
the universe it's not time it's it's
frequency it's different frequencies and
vibrations this is that's the language
of it all and these they deal with with
different ones so then my question is if
you had that deal with a demon what
would be worth your soul what level of
Fame whose life would you yeah but when
when does this come into the table when
does this conversation happen when you
die but you're trapped but you not what
do they give a sh what do they care
about you because they're feeding off my
anxiety and depression but they already
did but they'll feed off it again when I
die again and and it's almost like so so
is a contract negotiation when you die
it's almost like this like like yes it
is it's almost like it's almost like
confence like why why why am I going to
always use paper plates it's only one
use I'll just use this I'll just use me
I'm a glass plate and you clean me off
and use me again I'm cheaper but what
say do you have in the matter if they
control everything uh uh supposedly you
the only way that you can get supposedly
the only way that you can get
to getting out of that escape is of
course number one joining our patreon um
which we weeks yeah number number two
number two is kind of being this high
frequency highly operating
happy oscillating person that doesn't
allow like you almost have like nothing
for them to feed off so then they kind
of release you but a lot of people don't
know that I'm let me so what happens if
what happens if the first situation
happens uh like you said you ask me
which one I'm afraid of but the other
the second situation isn't dependent on
the first situation so what if someone
knocks out all of our power 100 million
people dying a month what are the lines
going to be like up there for those
contract negotiations it's going to take
forever it's going to take a while yeah
they got to process a 100 million it's
going take a while it is going to take a
while um where wait I I'll I'll try to
find this Reddit um did you go out and
buy the iodine and the Alfredo and like
the bigas Mas like in one clip were you
like did something make you be like you
know what we're going to be prepared I'm
going to and you just went out and did
that or has this been like like I don't
like how did you like when did you
gather that did you just say let's make
a basket a card on Amazon and run the
water and that was all in one moment
when you like you made a decision to do
that I made a decision to do that last
year I just went on an Amazon spree and
I did that we actually filmed the whole
podcast he wore a gas mask I think it's
just patreon yeah I did the whole thing
did you really yep is it
tenable yeah really it works and I've
night vision goggles tun kits anybody
want to break into the house and you
were able to do it it wasn't that
annoying no I just got it real quick the
um and also by the way next next uh
episode for the our New Year's episode I
will be making 2024 predictions I found
a nice Twitter thread that has made
genuine 2024 predictions and even if 5%
of these come true you know that we're
not alone here on this planet and the
and the entities might be in control oh
yeah let's keep with this um well let me
let me see if I can find this we'll do
some resolutions and some predictions
this is the Christmas episode if you
couldn't tell
yeah that guy David grush the alien guy
he did go on Rogan and kind of hinted at
they're interdimensional beings rather
than aliens right exactly Galactic
planetary right that they're that
they're that that this whole idea of
looking up to the heaven but how many
people okay is there a pecking order
where like the most powerful are looking
at everybody like we don't see anybody
we at the bottom are there other
entities that are like finding this out
about our entities let me read it for
the last years I've been researching the
nature of our reality who you have oh
you're reading something yeah I'm not
saying it's not me but it's not me okay
who or what controls our society from
the Shadows um what we do in the shadows
great show on
FX don't I know it I was on it it' be
something if both of us could be on it
wild and more importantly what actually
happens when the physical body dies and
the Soul leaves the body do we go to
heaven do we go to hell do we just cease
to exist is there a god that takes care
of us I believe yes and his name's Jesus
Christ once you begin to realize what's
actually going on and How Deep The
Rabbit Hole really goes you will never
see the world in the same way so buckle
up and get ready put your buckle
on thank you chest too but here's the
thing I I you you fill your head with
this and you're okay no well let me just
let me just I have ADHD and OCD and I my
OCD Tendencies make me Loop things and I
could Loop things as simple as a song
which still ends up driving you nuts
after a while but I could Loop these
existential end of the world scenarios
over and over and I walk around
basically like literally teetering on
the brink of a breakdown but I think
that that's because you're you're trying
to control it where if you just read it
and let it hit you and you realize you
don't have any control it's almost free
it almost frees you yeah but I don't try
to control it cuz
I I can't stop that right it's the way
my DNA is like I I mean I could do my
best at at mitigating it but like I
can't just be like oh you know what let
me just let it all go if you want to
change the way you think all the new
research you got to change your gut
microbiome and I could talk to you about
that after the show your gut microbiome
the Mind gut connection the evidence is
overwhelming that you literally are what
you eat and if you just change your gut
microbiome which I got a I got a I got a
service for you that you can literally
change the way you think and you can
have like a different personality but
let me get back to why the white tunnel
of light isn't real and reincarnation is
made up you know how anyone you know how
anyone who's had a near-death experience
talks about having seeing the tunnel
right
might appear in front of them or you've
met members of your family who passed
away in some rare cases even met and
spoke to those who you know said that
they were God right we've all heard this
my research this guy's on the Reddit
suggests that the tunnel of Light which
appears when we die is a trap designed
to wipe the whole memory of our last
Incarnation and to recycle our souls
into another body thus keeping us in an
infinite Loop here on Earth because of
this the overwhelming majority of people
walking the Earth have total Amnesia and
don't remember anything about their past
experiences nor anything from the
periods in between their lives I could
for lunch last week I couldn't yeah
there you go if you do some research
though you will notice that there is
however a small number of people
worldwide who are able to recall very
specific details regarding who they were
what they did for a living where they
lived in a past life Etc and they give
goes on to give five evidence examples
on YouTube how do we know these people
aren't making up their stories you'll
ask well there's lots of people out
there who have been able to bring very
solid pieces of evidence to sustain
their claims and those claims can be
verified corroborating evidence which
shows reincarnation is a very real
phenomenon confirming what many
religions claim to happen to the soul
when a person dies the reason these
people's memories have only been
partially erased and now fully erased
remains unknown for now so the astral
realm or the spirit realm is where the
reptilians and their agenda you've heard
of you know they you say Dick Cheney is
a reptile all that so this whole thing
about these reptilians who are the 1% of
possibly politicians and you you've seen
it all over YouTube they say this guy's
a reptilian that girls a reptilian
whatever they're saying that they live
in this astral Spirit realm and the
reptilians are found in the literature
of multiple ancient cultures across the
globe jism and Hindu talk about the Naga
n a
g it's it's an a at the end it's an a
it's the nagas um whom they describe as
as as half human half serpent uh
Serpentine no johanism and Hindu talk
about the Naga whom they describe as
half human half serpent um deities the
Aztecs used to worship the quas Coto
whom they described as the serpent like
God the hopy Indians in North America
referred to a race of reptoids called
the sheti translated snake Brothers in
Africa shamans claim to Bear extensive
esoteric knowledge of a race of
reptilian Bings called the
chaturi Chinese Korean Japanese Legends
talk about a race of reptilian beings
called the Capa and it goes on and on
and on and the reptilians have both
physical and are both physical and
astral beings um and they say that
they've been heavily involved in the
manipulation of mankind for thousands of
years and are responsible for setting up
the soul trap around the planet with the
help of extremely advanced technology
this energy grid around the planet
serves multiple purposes one of its main
purposes is to project this grandiose
tunnel of light in the proximity of
people who have just died in order to
lure their souls in this is the same
tunnel of light that so many people who
have had near-death experiences have
reported seeing on the other side the
soul may be under the impression that
the tunnel is going to take it to the
heavens or perhaps to a higher plane of
existence depending on its level of
awareness in reality when a soul enters
this tunnel its memory gets wiped and
the soul is put into another body here
on Earth reincarnation the tunnel acts
as bait and to make a good analogy
imagine a fisherman in his fishing rod
he throws in the bait which hides The
Hook and the fish gets trapped in it
when they bite we get tricked and
trapped by the tunnel of light in a
similar way if we aren't if we aren't
aware that it is a trap in this case
we're the fish the reptilians are highly
intelligent highly Advanced
technologically and they lack empathy
which makes them dangerous these beings
see themselves as God and Humanity as
their enslaved cattle how you
doing how you doing
oh I'm unclear his ass I'm unclear uh
how I feel about panakot right I just
want to change the subject yes what is
panakot I'm just I'm like I don't want
to believe any of this stuff man this is
crazy this is uh yeah I mean I'll send
you the do you believe in any of this or
anybody believe in any of this let me
ask you a question
but
but but everyone can have a like I I I
mean true true everyone can have a the
there's no way to prove or disprove any
of it right but it just has an
ulterior thing I know but that that
gives you too much to think
about it's not the craziest idea in the
world to me anymore that's all I'm
saying I don't I I don't well we can't
explain anything else we can't explain
what our existence we can't explain that
listen years a big bang what was there
before the Big Bang infinite Infinity
that doesn't make any sense Infinity it
doesn't make any sense right so the so
what's at the end who who or or at the
beginning I mean cuz if I would have
told you 10 years ago all you guys 10
years ago that there's reptilian now was
this weight when you right yeah that 10
years ago you know reptilians were
ruling the planet and feeding on our
souls you know for their energy we would
say you're literally crazy putting you
in insane asylum and now I say it
because of so much stuff that has
happened and so much except the Internet
is exposed where you're like I'm not
saying I fully believe it but I'll hear
you out and not think you're absolutely
crazy I could hypothetically believe it
wow yeah that's true right isn't that
true same with aliens you're almost
crazier now if you don't believe in
aliens correct you're crazier if you
don't right where it used to be we grew
up in the time where you were nuts if
you believed you would be like how could
that be and now it's obviously that
there but what our aliens and are they
interdimensional are they in outer space
are these aliens the reptilians are they
future versions of us I don't know no so
does all of this when you when you take
it all in and you think about all the
different people that have theories and
all the stuff that is unknown and all
the stuff that could happen at any
minute we are just like a powder keg
right of all this stuff right and we
don't know where we're going where we
came from what we're doing what our
purpose is who we are and it could all
end at any minute or
not so shouldn't we just do whatever we
want I don't mean that in a deviant way
I just mean like I should just moon walk
around naked from now on eating pizza
and don't don't do anything need want to
do well not that I want to do that but I
wouldn't do it but now I know that I can
do it well that the thing is put me away
reptilians people what what these
theorists would say is second walk
outside they put me away naked naked but
get naked the reptilians the reptilians
because us even wearing clothes and the
rules of society and all that is just
for us to feel insecurities which they
feed off but the actual just laws of the
universe is like you're born naked be
naked there's no reason to wear clothes
if you were if they Universe want you to
wear clothes you get you'd be born with
with clothes on but
a like a like a like a doll out of a box
yeah what do you got P well I think uh
isn't AI when you can put your soul into
the robot isn't that going to [__] that
all
up I don't know yeah now that's a whole
new frontier right there like what we're
talking about downloading our our
sensient soul and mind now and and
putting it on something else about we're
getting a little tricky now what about
the theories that we always get to this
point in Civilization and then it starts
over that we've done this this is the
85th million that one blew my balls off
too thanks so if you're if you're
watching thank you for tuning in to the
Christmas episode of hey bab yes Merry
Christmas we just wanted to give you
guys things to talk about tonight with
your family well It All Leads up to this
It All Leads up to this people say
Santa's not real right but we know now
he is a reptilian who is feeding off all
of our good nature Santa is a Naga
that's why he has a list of nordian nice
right he is a he has a list of nian nice
and he feeds Fe off that that naughty
list he does feed off that naughty list
yeah yes Santa and he feeds off that so
if you want to get gifts this year then
just be nice operate at a high frequency
because if you're operating at that
negative frequency not only you not get
gifts but he is feeding off your soul
and your your power but you could be
powering a sled that's the thing I tell
you I saw Santa for real I'm dead
serious what happened so nobody believes
me but thankfully my sister was there
and so we maintain this together because
we saw it together and I don't know how
to explain it but I'm being dead serious
so take take this however you like it
when we were younger but of age enough
like I would
say we were probably you know like 10 8
something like that of age mhm we we
used to celebrate on Christmas Eve and
my dad would put us to bed and then they
wake us up at midnight to open the gifts
so around 8:00 7 o'clock they'd send us
to bed and of course we were always too
excited and we could never fall asleep
and we'd always listen for him to come
because he always came and he was we
heard him talking and he he'd jet after
that and we'd come out and get the gifts
so one time me and my sister in the bed
in my dad's room like supposed to be
sleeping and we just he had a window
right at the foot of his bed and so
we're looking out the window we're
talking and look this is what I saw I
saw a Santa in his sleigh with
reindeer in the air flying across the
sky like miles away right across the
moon so I could see the perfect
silhouette my sister was right there we
didn't say nothing to each other and
then I just looked I said do you see
what I'm seeing and she said yeah I said
what are you what are you seeing she
goes it's Santa it's Santa on a sleigh
with all of his reindeer and I'm like
you see exactly what I'm seeing she's
like yeah we just watched it and we
watched it cross over the moon and we
watched it keep going now I didn't see
like I saw we saw it in the sky and then
it especially saw it over the moon when
it passed the silhouette we both saw it
together it was for like a full freaking
minute we watched it together confirm
what we were looking at in the sky and
it pass and to this day we both maintain
it have no idea what it is what we saw
how that's even feasible but we both saw
it with our own eyes s you know what
that was what that was Malaysian flight
been Merry
Christmas don't Be a fake don't be a
flake don't run away from your feelings
babe don't be afraid don't be ashamed
don't hesitate say hey babe hey bab hey
bab hey bab hey babe hey babe